we got the story from spiked and I
always love to give you guys the news
guard certification 100 out of 100
that's right it is newsguard certified
and people are like that's the
government so the government certified
it would call whatever you want Joe
Biden's Sinister disinformation campaign
they say last week it was revealed that
shortly before the 2020 election Joe
Biden's presidential campaign conspired
with 51 former spies to discredit the
New York Post discoveries from the
hunter Biden laptop that is to say a
person running for office conspired with
government officials
to discredit a news story that could
harm their campaign and by the way when
Michael Morrell was asked under oath uh
why he did it he said it was because he
wanted Joe Biden to be elected he just
straight up said that
because you can get away with it right
it's a two-tier system yeah
they let you when you're famous
oh my gosh
so uh well there you go does this mean
that the country doesn't exist or
something
it means it's not our country anymore
yeah it's like being worn as a skin suit
by a cult
be corrupt individuals just do whatever
they want we're sitting here watching
how you doing
yeah I'm I'm doing all right with it you
know I'm doing all right obviously you
know talk about this a bit my hope is is
not in this world I think we could still
win this battle though no I think we're
winning I think I think it simply comes
down to uh the reason they're going
after kids so much is because they know
that if they don't they're done
20 years from knowledge conservative
kids are going to be like I vote against
you and they're not gonna have kids
because you know they sterilize and
support them so you know but also the
thing is if they do go after the kids
and really normalize pedophilias they're
clearly starting to do and gearing up to
do then there's no way for us to win
like we've once that is taken from you
once they win that there's nothing I I I
I just disagree I mean there's too much
required to get to that point where a
conservative can't just move to the
middle of nowhere and keep their kids
away from this stuff yeah the fact that
you'd have to move to the middle of
nowhere to get away from people trying
to abuse your kids means you have lost
the society you actually can't do that
now because now California and uh I
forget what other state but another
state as well have passed law Washington
was it Washington was this are you
talking about the um the
um Sanctuary thing the so they passed
they passed laws that if you're if
you're in a marital dispute over your
child transitioning one parent can take
that child and go to California and then
um and then the other and then that
court that case will be adjudicated in
California not in the state of the other
parents so basically you can kidnap your
kid and then there was another law that
was passed in California
um that was I can't remember it past or
if it's set to be passed but that's
basically instructing judges that when
they hear these kinds of cases
essentially telling them to lean in
favor of transitioning being in the
welfare of the child so in other words
you can move to wherever you want to but
if you're in the U.S and you have a
dispute with your with your spouse over
this your spouse can just take your kid
to California so Harbor
and there was also something else I saw
the other day about uh I'd have to pull
up the state again but they just passed
legislation saying that these shelters
don't have to report runaways to their
parent if they're identify as trans and
that's why they've run away your kid can
check into a residential rehab facility
without the consent of their parents it
just takes like a social worker or a
psychologist saying yeah I think that
this isn't the kid's best and undergo
abortion services and also gender
transition hormone therapy I don't know
if surgery is included but some hormone
sex change procedures are without the
consent of either parent yeah well and
this is the new paradigm right
historically our understanding was
parents have the final say over what
happens to their child and if the
government is going to get involved they
need to prove that they have a very good
reason they need to demonstrate that
this child is being abused to the point
where the state has to step in now it's
the exact opposite the state has the
final say over what your kid gets to do
the parent has to prove that they should
have their concerns heard about their
own child the law law in California that
is just referred to actually the the law
was they took the existing statute which
said that a kid can check into a
residential rehab facility if number one
a psychologist or social worker
something recommends it and number two
that that kid has been abused or a
victim of incest in the household in
those cases the prior law was in those
cases that kid could go to residential
rehab facility without the parents
consent that's a good law that makes
sense right the new law just struck out
the part about abuse or victim of incest
well they're going to say the parents of
the abusers for not willing to
transition to kids because it's
projection because it's projection
because the left never says we're not
doing that or what we're doing isn't as
bad as what you think they say you're
doing it we're not abusing these kids
you're abusing these kids
right
so it's state kidnapping yeah that's
basically what it is it's the state is
allowed to kidnap your kid so like I
didn't watch the full video with what
Biden said I'd watch the little segment
where he was talking about you know your
you don't own your kids or whatever so I
I don't want to speak to what what the
context was I don't want to be surprised
by with but it is sort of like in the
context of these laws that are being
passed I feel like like in the I tweeted
about this like 20 years ago the
religious right used to talk about how
the left wanted to destroy the nuclear
family and at the time I thought that
was ridiculous and Hyperbole and it
probably was ridiculous and hyperbole at
the time
but now it's like it's hard to it's like
well that's actually what these laws
amount to they're saying that the
parents shouldn't have doesn't need to
give consent that that the biggest
threats to the children come from the
parents and that the state and
psychologists and social workers need to
take custody of that kid to protect them
from their parents Sanctuary stage now
for 16 surgeries yep what did Joe Biden
just say today Seamus he said that you
don't basically that you don't own your
child the nation does he's like it's not
your kid it's not someone else's kid
it's the nation's kid to paraphrase what
a creep yeah it's extremely creepy yeah
I get to sniff you can't tell me not to
sniff their hair man
we're gonna get those hairs in my
nostrils
um but I I think to what you're saying
that it's probably true that your your
average liberal person 20 years ago
wasn't going about the Revolutionary
change that they were trying to in state
by saying I I want to destroy the family
but all of the intellectual thought
leaders of the left going back decades
did openly say that that was their goal
true I mean yeah the the radical Fringe
of the left
um was definitely saying those things
like the the nuclear family is an
oppressive structure blah blah blah blah
you know and who cares right because
there's a radical Fringe on the left
there's a radical fridge on the right
and they're all crazy and we can just
like ignore them for the most part that
used to be the case and now I mean so
that's the difference right it was like
normal Normie liberals deaf and it's
Remains the case that normally liberals
don't want to destroy the nuclear family
but we are in a situation in which those
radical Fringe activists now are can't
be ignored anymore because they live
they they they have power over state
legislators and they have power over you
know Federal legislators arguably but
certainly state legislators in
California so now this stuff is becoming
law and it's going to spread because
they're what's happening on the left
right now too is they're working with
younger people to get them elected into
these offices uh Moms Demand Action some
of the anti-gun organizations are
working with 18 to 24 year olds to teach
them and train them how to get into
these positions so they can start
changing the law from the inside and
expanding that agenda yeah
welcome to the new country I guess I'm
still confident that uh we're gonna win
though
I just I I just think it's math we can
talk about all the things they want to
do to kids and how they want to create
these Sanctuary States but the reality
is if you keep your kids away from this
this cultural influence they've lost so
I think part of what you're saying is
that when people do the right thing and
have good ideas and behave virtuously in
the long run they win because people are
doing bad things and behaving in vicious
ways end up eating themselves alive and
their society collapses but if the rot
spreads so far within your culture that
it completely usurps it well then your
entire civilization collapses before
that good can eventually win out once
people try to rebuild From the Ashes and
I'm not saying that that's a guarantee
here what I am saying is I agree with
you that in the long run good wins but
that doesn't mean America is still
around 100 years from now America will
be around it just won't be the same and
I'm not saying that there won't be a
collapse a long fall or a civil war or
whatever I'm just I know you're not
saying there won't be a civil war yeah
the ride's gonna win
it's basically it's it there's like
historical precedence very rarely do the
the I mean let's put it this way the
left are they aren't anti-gun Liberals
are anti-gun yeah the left likes guns
but you still can't compare compare a
soy boy to like a military veteran and
the left likes to show these big fat
militia guys and they're like haha like
that guy could go toe-to-toe with a
national Guardsman and it's like dude
the National Guard will be split the
same as any other part part of this
country and I got I got I got news for
these guys the big fat militia guy
probably is still better trained with a
gun than a soy boy and someone like left
us an antifa guy the left has the John
Brown gun club and like a bunch of these
you know was it the Socialist Rifle
Association or whatever and those guys
are probably a lot better with weapons
but that big fat militia guy is going to
be better than the average
thin scrawny vegan soy boy dude I mean
isn't it really hyper polarizing though
to see these two distinct these distinct
individuals the stereotypes on the right
you have The Stereotype of the morbidly
obese militia guy and on the left you
have the gaunt and frail antifa guy
isn't it kind of weird maybe something
to do with being vegan
no offensive vegans I got no beef I'm
just saying you know a lot of vegans
aren't getting enough protein they don't
got no beef either bro quite literally
no beef no beef yeah so I I don't know a
long story short
I just don't see how the left can
possibly win if they don't have kids I
mean one thing to pay attention to is
that a lot of the stuff with the Trans
stuff and I want to stipulate this by
saying I do not have a problem with
adults transitioning don't care that's
fine do what you want to it's the the
kids who who concerns me but a lot of
the it's the The Bluest cities in the
blue Estates where a lot of this where
the most affirming is happening both not
just at the medical level but also in
the schools and just in the general
culture so it's parents of kids who are
gender questioning or whatever in those
in in your Brooklyns and in your San
Francisco's who are coming face to face
with the Stark reality of of of how deep
and pervasive this stuff is and they're
getting red pilled like when they see
this happening to their own kid their
kid is questioning they're supportive
right they're like being super
supportive they know the right things to
do but then they go to the the the
therapist of their therapist is like oh
well your kid is definitely trans and we
need to put them on hormones they're
like what you gotta
they might go further even but then the
kid starts to regret it and then it
becomes this whole mess and then the
parents are studying this stuff along
the way they're they're looking up you
know these are like you know these are
like you know uh upper middle class
laptop classes people they're looking up
the medical studies they're reading the
medical studies they're realizing that
there's actually no medical basis to the
claim that puberty blockers are
reversible they're all that stuff and
then they start to question everything
and then 95 of dysphoric people grow out
of it in puberty right there was a story
about a family who said that they're
they were very leftist very pro-trans
very supportive until one day their son
came out and said he was trans and they
were like what that's no you're not and
so they started talking like to him and
to each other like you have no symptoms
of this you don't show nothing of this
why are why are you saying this when
they brought the kid into counselors and
stuff the counselor said no he no he's
definitely trans and then they said
these things aren't true though
basically like the kid was saying oh
yeah I used to do this I used to do that
I used to this and the parents were like
no no that's not true yeah and they were
like you're just denying your son's
lived experience and all these things
and this the family then basically said
we realized a lot of this stuff was
being pushed on our kid who was just
trying to fit in and going along with it
and it was freaky to see the whole
machine pushing in this direction yeah
to make your kidney by the way a hugest
proportion of those kids are autistic as
well right they don't know stock stuff
they don't know how to uh to fit in
socially right and so when someone says
this is what's socially acceptable they
disagree right it's easy to blame all
your problems you know your if you were
abused do you have trauma whatever
um you have other mental disorders all
this stuff and it's like somebody comes
with you with a solution they're like oh
well all of this is a clear sign of
gender dysphoria and all you have to do
is take this drug and everything will be
okay thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time